- Sumo wrestling is a game of seconds.
However, there's months of training
that go within those seconds.
Imagine it’s like an earthquake
that's building and building and building,
and all of the sudden, there's
this huge explosion,
all at one time.
That's what sumo is.
I'm really just a normal guy.
I'm a husband.
I'm a father of three.
I'm the director of technology
for the county office
of education.
I'm also an America sumo wrestler.
- Sumo has a long history in Japan.
Some people trace it back
up to 1,500 or 2,000 years,
but it's essentially, you know, wrestling,
where you either want to push
your opponent out of the ring,
or knock your opponent to the ground.
People have an image that sumo wrestlers
are basically just bumping bellies,
and wobbling around,
and as you can see from the practice here,
nothing's further from the truth.
Roy's amazing, he basically
came out of nowhere.
He showed up to the 2014 US Sumo Open,
and blew everyone's mind.
He beat every single American opponent.
With almost no training,
he's already the number one American.
- To be a competitive sumo wrestler,
you need to train hard.
Whether I'm stretching,
whether I'm power-lifting,
whether I'm working out with rocks,
I'm always looking for the edge.
The thing that really brought me to sumo
was the fact that there
was culture and sport,
all kinda mixed in one.
It seemed like a perfect fit.
For example, when you stomp the ground,
you're ridding the area of bad spirits,
and when you make your first clap,
you're waking up the gods.
- You know, he is a gentle giant,
and he doesn't want to hurt anybody,
and sumo's great that way,
because, you know, they're just trying
to get each other out of the ring,
they're not trying to knock each other out
or really hurt one another.
- I think sumo has that camaraderie,
fraternity aspect to it.
You know, we're banging
heads, we're going at it.
At the end of it, there's still
this higher level of respect.
I guess as a pacifist, that
definitely appeals to me.